نساء وفتيات يتدفق شعرهن يرقصن في
تجمع في باريس من أجل حياة المرأة
الحرية شعار
الحركة المناهضة للحكومة في إيران ولكن حتى هنا
بقوة داخل حدود أوروبا
يقول الناشطون إن مخالب طهران يمكن أن
تصل وتسحق أصوات النسب
الناشط ماسكوماري فر هنا إلى فرنسا
حول  منذ أربع سنوات
كلاجئة سياسية منذ وجودي هنا، أستطيع أن
أشرح مشاعري بحرية، وأحاول أن أكون
صوت شعبي الذي يعاني في إيران،
لكن كماري تقول إنها سرعان ما وجدت
نفسها تحت التهديد مرة أخرى، وتقول إن
جهاز المخابرات الإيراني كان
تضايق والديها في المنزل
ويطالبونها بالتحدث معها، لقد أخذوا
هاتف والدتي ودفعوني
وأجبروني على الاتصال
بهاتف والدتي ثم كان هناك رجل
أجاب فأجاب هذا الرجل
والدتك نعم بالضبط كماري تقول  لقد
سجلت مكالمة تقشعر لها الأبدان مع رجل
تعتقد أنه عضو في
المخابرات الإيرانية على الرغم من أن CNN لا تستطيع التحقق من
أن
أي إجراءات تتخذها ضد
الجمهورية الإسلامية هناك في فرنسا تعتبر
جريمة يقول الرجل وعائلتك سوف
تجيب عليها
لا يا سيدي هي ترد  لا يوجد قانون في أي مكان في العالم
يقول إن والدتك ستؤخذ إلى
سجن إيفون في سنها
وسيتم نقل أختك وتابعتك أيضًا إلى
سجن إيفون وسيتم استجوابهم،
كان الأمر صعبًا للغاية أعني لأنني لا
أفهم كيف  إلى الحد الذي يمكن لهؤلاء الناس أن يذهبوا إليه، تقوم
الجمهورية الإسلامية
بقمع الانتفاضة الشعبية التي
هزت البلاد لعدة أشهر،
ويلعب المنشقون في الخارج دورًا حاسمًا في
هذه الحركة التي تحمل
مطالب المحتجين من شوارع إيران إلى
قاعات الحكومات الغربية،
وهذا هو بالضبط سبب إيران  توسع
حملتها القمعية، يقول هذا الناشط
منذ ثلاثة عقود، إنها حقيقة أن
النظام الإيراني لديه السلطة لكننا نحن
المعارضة ولكننا
أعتقد أن العديد لدينا جسر ولكن
مع اليوم الناس في الداخل
والناس  في الخارج وليس هناك مكان آمن، كان من
الممكن أن أقتل في يناير/كانون الثاني،
كشفت وزارة العدل الأمريكية عن مؤامرة
لاغتيال معارضة إيرانية بارزة
بالقرب من منزلها في بروكلين،
وحذرت وزارة الخارجية من أن طهران
متورطة في أعمال قمع أخرى عابرة للحدود الوطنية
للتخويف أو
الانتقام منها.  أفراد خارج
الحدود السيادية للبلاد
وفقًا لتقرير صدر عام 2022. ولم يتم
الرد على طلب CNN للسلطات الإيرانية في الوقت
الحالي. تقول كاماري إن والديها آمنان
لكنها بالكاد تتحدث إليهما كإجراء
احترازي، كيف لا تزالين تخرجين
وتقومين بعملك؟  لأنني لن
أتوقف عن أنشطتي لأنهم يهددونني
بمجتمع نقدي في المنفى تحت
التهديد والضغط ولكن لا ينحنى
ولا يخاف
بعض هؤلاء Z's CNN Paris